done
はぁんっ
はぁんっん
[音楽]
ん
me
皆さんが住んでいる町
この街を自分で作ろうと思ったことある人いいますかこのない街を作る
いう方ですここで手が上がったら僕の話ここで終わるので
ああ
あの僕は仕事を通じて気づいたことがありますそれは自分のまちは自分で作るという
ことなんです
今日は僕から自分のまちは自分で作る
そんな話をしたいと思います
もともと僕は建設資材のメーカーに勤めていました
そうですねちょうどその頃今から5年前
ある事件が起きたんですそれは
僕の大好きな実家の周りがスラム街になってしまったんです
それは実家の
賃貸住宅で起こったことなんです
ば時代の流れで空室がどんどん増えていって
ついにそのうちの1頭が
全員退去して空き家になってしまったんです完全に
これです
まあ寂れた雰囲気ちょっと怖い感じですよね
そう僕が小さい時にはすごくにぎやかだったんですこのあたりもお店がたくさんあって
子供もたくさんいた
ただ40年間で様変わりしてしまいました
でここで収入がなくなってしまったのでこの建物を維持することができなくなって
しまったんですそこで
父親が僕に相談をくれました
ちょっとどうしようかな
僕行ったんです
そしたらこの建物の使い方とか見た目をごそっと変えて
全面改修してもう一度
賃貸事業やり直そうって言ったんですそうしたら
父王が
やめとけやめとけど
そんな金掛けてどないすんねここにはもう一こないぞ
相談しておいてなんで反対するないと思ったんですけど
そうなんですいや実はここ立地が悪いところなんです
今までいろんなことをやったんですけどなかなか上手くいかなかっただから反対するの
もしょうがないなと思いました
だけど反対を押し切って
その全面改修をスタートさせるんです
それは僕には信念があったんです
自分が住みたいなと思う家をつくったら必ずそれに応えて人が来てくれるという信念が
ありました
だからこの全面改修には僕がいいなと思うことをたくさん盛り込んだんです
床は無垢のフローリング気持ちがいいんです
壁は自由に塗ってもいいんです神聖衣にしました
そしてリビングはどうもあの広い土間にしたんです
arturia のようにしたんです普通の賃貸住宅ではあまり見られない仕様なん
です
僕はこの建物2位のハウスという名前をつけました
自然素材のイノセンスと革命のイノベーションという犬をかけてそしたら面白かったん
です驚いたことに
工事中にもかかわらずたくさん問い合わせをいただいて完成前に満室になったんです
そしてもっと面白かったのがここに集まった人たち
デザイナー革職人イラストレーター
すごくクリエイティブでアクティブな人たちが集まったんです
なんだが一体感があってこれ面白そうなことが起こりそうなそんな感じがしました
でこれは完成パーティーの時なんです住民の日とその友達
それから街の人
たくさんの人が集まったんです半年前までにはここに人が来ないと言われた場所です
にぎわいが生まれたんです
そしてこの賑わいがこの後も続いていくんです
なんか
日常が変わってきたなそんな感じがしました
何気な挨拶が増えたんです
この建物の前とか人がいないと言われたところに何か人が外に出ているんです僕も用も
ないのに行きたくなった
賃貸経営を何とか立て直したいその思いで仲間と一緒にいのハウスを作ったんですけど
何か想定とは違う何が別のものを町に作れた
そういうふうに思ったんですあーこれって何かなーと思ったんです
これ街づくりだって思ったんです
よしこれを仕事にしようってその時思いました
このまちづくりは自分のやるべきことだってそういうふうに強く思ったんです強く思っ
ちゃったから会社を辞めました
会社を辞めて
それで街づくり量をしようと
この五ノハウスで起こったことがずーっと
街に広がったらこれ絶対面白いことになってそういうふうに思ったんです
ずっと広く考えるとちょっとイメージしづらかったです
いろいろ合意形成とか大変だなそこで
祖父の代から管理しているこの五ノハウスを含む
ちょうど直径100m のこの小さなエリア
ここに小さな町を作ろう直径100m の町を作ろうそう決心するんです
そしてこの場所の真ん中の空き地の空き地にみんなで考えた想いを込めた
賃貸住宅をまず立てることを決めて
それでこの小さな町に名前を付けることにしたんです
井野タウンでいう名前をつけました
じゃあ今度は位のハウスと怒ったようにこの位のタウンに
このクリエイティブでアクティブな人に来てもらいたい
どうすればいいか
この企画にはすでに入居している
デザイン事務所が参画してくれたんです
すでにいる人たちが主役になってこの場所を面白くするにはどうすればいいか一緒に
考えてくれたんです
やっぱりすごいことだと思います
そしてみんなで考えるんですこの小さな町にどうやったら
そういうクリエイティブな人たちが来てくれるか
いや自分で作れる部屋を作ろう
そう集まった人たちがイベントをできる広場を作ろう
みんなが使える公民館のようなカフェを作ろう
ギャラリーを作ろう
シェアオフィスを作ろういろいろ企画をして工事がスタートします
あの国銀行に行ってもう羽成お金を陰狩り的でですねもうこれ後には控えめせません
もうドキドキなんですこれ
建物が建って餅をまきます
そうしたら街の人が200人ぐらい集まってくれました
すごいですよね
で工事中にまあルシオやりました
地域の人たちが手伝ってくれているすぐを盛り上がりました
建物が完成して完成パーティーの時にもまたたくさんの人が来てくれたんです
すごい嬉しかったです
そして募集をかけますそしたらこの街に住みたいという人
この街にお店を出したいという人
できたカフェにコーヒーを飲みに来てくれる人
いろんな人が集まったんです人が人を呼ぶ感覚
すごく嬉しかったです
してもっとさらに面白かったのが集まった人たちがいろんな企画するんです音楽
イベント
これ去年なんですけれども入居者さん同士で話してクリスマスのマジックショーをやり
ました
それから
あのマルシェもやります
こんなところに
人は来ないよと言われた場所ににぎわいが生まれたんです
街ができたんです
一般的にまちづくりっていうのは
住みやすい住環境づくり全般のことだとか
あと自治体レベルの都市計画なんかをさしたりします少し大きなこと
だけど僕たち仲間で位の端をつくっていく中で
大切だなって思ったのはもっと身近なことに目を向けることも
大切だなというふうに思うんです例えばふとした日常が楽しいだとか
一人一人が小さなことから始めるまあそんなことです
いのターンにいたら挨拶があるんですおはようこんにちは
あと
それ以外にも
名前で割るんです僕あの下の名前が takahiro なので
孝宏さんと呼ばれるんです
昨日通してターン
最近どうとか人に関心持ったりもたれたりカフェに入ったら僕の知ってる人がいて僕の
ことを知っている人がいる
そういうふとした
人と人とのつながりちょっと深い一つの人がのつながり
これがふとした日常は楽しいなって感じることに繋がると思うんです
この人と人とのつながり
community
だから僕は街づくりっていうのはコミュニティーづくりに置き換えられると思うんです
じゃあこの community どうやって作るかそしてどうやって継続するかこれ
が課題なんです
で僕たちが
小さなまちづくりをやる中で
気づいた3つありますそれは同室の人を集める
ば御設ける
きっかけづくりができる人を見つける
この同室の人を集めるというのは
同じような価値観を持った人のことを言いますそういう人たちが集まれば
共感性が高まるんですよ共感性が高まるコミュニティって盛り上がるんですね
井野タウンではこういう工夫があります
あえて収納作らず自分で作ってくださいとか
腫れは自由に自分で縫ってもいいんです
こういうクリエーティブな感覚を刺激するような仕掛けをたくさん入れることによって
それが楽しいそれがいいという人だけが集まって入居するです
なので共感性の高いコミュニティが生まれるんです場を設ける人が集まるためには
場所
が必要なんです
じゃあどんな場所でもいいのかいやそうじゃないんです
やっぱり運営が必要なんですよ毎日行きたいなって思えるような場所が必要です
毎日行きたいなと思える場所じゃどうするか
井野タウンでは賃貸住宅の中にカフェを作りました
このカフェは収益を目的としたカフェじゃなくコミュニティ形成を目的としてしてい
ます
公民館のようなカフェ
そして次にきっかけづくりができる人を見つける
これ実は重要なんです
例えば
集まりがあって
ただ人が集まってだ何か起こりませんじゃあのみかやろうとか何かイベントを企画する
ような一大事ですよねこういう人
こういう人が必要なんです
でいい濃淡ではどういう風に
あの工夫をしたかというと住宅と店舗を複合的に
作るんです
実はこの店舗お店
お店というのは商売上
街がにぎわうことと利害が一致するんです
街がにぎわったらを見せ儲かりますから
なのでお店を実際
街であっても積極的に入れて
それでその
お店の人がコミュニティのきっかけ作りをやってくれるんです
だけか
継続したコミュニティが生まれる
同室の人は
ある場所に集まって
そこにきっかけを作る人がいれば
共感性の高いコミュニティが生まれるんです
共感性の高いコミュニティーは2回3回続くんです
人も増えるんですそうしたらその増えたらまたその中にきっかけを作る人がまたいるん
です
それで継続していくんですこの検測っていうのがいいんですよ
こうやって僕の周りでは町の拠点が
増えていっているんです
何にもない住宅街の中にあるアパートの一室
空き家だったんです
ここに地域の
一人の女性が在宅ワーカーが集まる拠点としてコトノハコっていう場所を作りました
レンタルボックスを置いたら地域の作家がたくさん集まって自分の作品をここに置いて
販売するんですそして
ワークショップをすればそこに街の人が集まってにぎわいが生まれるんです
ただの空き家です町の拠点になりました
シャッター街化が進む商店街の中で
うまく起こったことなんです
20年前に閉店したとんかつ屋さん
ここが空き家になってたんですでここに1回にコミュニティカフェをつくって2階に
外国人が宿泊できる
ゲストハウスを吐く竜 com 症でしょう
そしたらこの1回に外国人と町の人が交流を深めるんです
ミシンを置いたらものづくりが始まりました
面白い場所になって言ってでこの場所
地域の初増加にかしたら
いろんなイベントが起こるようになりました
それでまた人が人を呼ぶにぎわいが生んだんです
さっきの奴とこれ両方とも元々はただの空き家だったんです
僕たちは
空き家を
町の拠点に再生することでまちづくりをやって言ってます
実はこのまちづくりというのは
誰でもできるんです
この出発前となる場所はどこでもいいと思うんです
例えばミニさんの身近にあるような
行き付けのカフェとか公園とか自分の家とかでもいいと思うんですそこに気の合う仲間
と集まってまちづくりを始めませんか
なんで皆さんにこういうことを言うかというと
みなさんの街の主役は皆さん一人ひとりなんです
して他人が作るものではないんです
ふとした日常が楽しいなーって思える街は
自分ひとりひとりで作るんです
最後に
僕から言います
いつどこで誰とあなたは始めますか
ありがとう
[拍手]